for many of us millions billions
trillions lacks crores lead to severe
confusion actually lacks and crores come
under the indian numbering system and
millions billions and trillions come
under the international numbering system
first we shall understand the
international numbering system let us
begin with one thousand
now one thousand times one thousand
gives us one million we have six zeros
now one million multiplied by one
thousand gives us one billion now this
has nine zeros
and one billion multiplied by one
thousand gives us one trillion and this
has twelve zeros if we notice carefully
we will observe that in the
international number system we multiply
by one thousand every time to get the
next set
in the indian numbering system let us
start with one thousand one thousand
multiplied by one hundred gives us one
lakh now this has five zeros
and one lakh multiplied by one hundred
gives us one crore now this has seven
zeros
so if you notice the main difference is
that in the indian numbering system we
keep multiplying by 100 to get the next
set while in the international numbering
system we multiply by 1000 now we will
look at a few examples in the next part
of this video